me and my husband were we were on baby
step 2 for a while and then we went back
to baby step one um ever since 2019 we
like bought a house and then we ended up
getting cars because our cars were
falling apart and um we were having a
baby and all that stuff so anyway when
we bought the house they said we needed
to get a new roof within the next year
or two and that was 2019 so now it's
2023 and we need a new roof and it's
going to be like $7,000 and we don't
have anything saved for it and we're
figure like we told you not to buy a
house while you're in debt and you did
it anyway yeah pretty much not pretty
much you did me and my husband are on
different we my husband doesn't have the
same mindset as me um so where yeah so
where's his money for the roof he didn't
have it with his mindset does he I can't
help you until you guys decide you're
ready to change your lives I kind of
think you are cuz I kind of hear fear in
your voice I think you're scared